[Music]
BBC series the cry came to an end this
week with fans finally learning the fate
of baby Noah and Alistair throughout
this video I'll be discussing the show's
ending and what message it carries with
it there will of course be heavy
spoilers so it may be worth skipping
this video for now if you want to watch
the final episode with fresh eyes with
that out the way I'm definition and I
ruin the show so you don't have to in
the finale of the cry we discover that
it was in fact Alistair that killed baby
Noah he inadvertently did this after not
testing the medicine properly before
giving it to the child which led to the
infant's death he concocted the plan to
pretend that Noah had gone missing after
he was found dead in the car angered by
the fact that Alistair tried to blame
Joanna she sought revenge and murdered
him she managed to do this by him
buckling his seat belt so that when she
crashed the car he flew out the window
and was killed due to the nature of the
murder Joanna was able to convince the
jury that it was an accident
and she left court without being
convicted in the final scenes of the
show what we see Joanna now living in
Australia completely haunted by the
ghost of Alistair during the court
hearing she hallucinating that he was
there watching over her and it's evident
that though she has been cleared of the
charges she has not been cleared of her
torment she delivers a monologue to the
vision of Alistair protesting how she
was a good mother in spite of all the
things that happened and it's a touching
moment that also hammers home just how
much she is now dealing with severe
mental illness in the house another
vision of Alistair appears and asks to
have another child with her to me this
signifies that she does not actually
feel guilty for what she has done nor
does she truly accept how badly the two
were as parents Alistair was
manipulative and had a horrendous
sinister side that was not fit to father
it shows just how truly lost your honor
is by the fact that she still thinks
both would be fit to
it's a child Juwanna isn't willing to
accept the fact that she is a murderer
and this is showcased by her
justification that she was a good mother
and therefore a good person in her head
she is still more than capable of having
another family and even believes that
she deserves one this highlights that
she is unwilling to accept any blame
however her subconsciousness refuses to
lie to her and this is why visions of
Alistair will forever continue to haunt
her and tell she comes clean it's a
somber reminder that no bad deed goes
unpunished and though she may be
acquitted of her crimes she will forever
go on to live in a mental prison another
theory about the show is that joanna was
never actually acquitted for the crime
and that she's just hallucinating her
perfect life down the road in a recent
interview with the express producers
stated that they wanted to make every
episode feel slightly different to the
last one the truth is often bent
throughout the series and it's
interesting to see how this culminates
in a finale Joana is more than capable
enough of not accepting guilt and
therefore hallucinating a completely
different life I know this could be seen
as a bit of a reach but it definitely
makes sense especially when you look at
the shows a stake director Glenn Dylan
Ivan revealed to the Express it's a
story that doesn't actually show you
anything and it's constantly hiding what
it's about and that continues - episode
2 3 & 4 each one has a different feel
and you can go back and watch every
episode again and you'll see that it's
almost two very different stories
happening in front of you
this backs up my theory that Johanna
could be imagining the whole event and
this is why she is still haunted by
visions of Alistair we will of course
have to wait to see if a season two is
created to know this for sure but it's
definitely a thought-provoking end and I
took a lot from it so what what are your
thoughts on the ending of the cry did
you manage to predict the reveals and
what was the thing that shocked you the
most do you agree with my theory and if
not tell me below in the comments if you
enjoyed this video please check out my
breakdown at the ending of The Bodyguard
which will be linked at the end of this
one this is a channel for fans of films
games TV and more so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe if you'd
like to help us out so we can bring
content like this to you every week
please donate to the page
Triana which is linked in the
description thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best not see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]